as an EU citizen or company you have the
right to live work study or do business
in any EU country Iceland Norway or
Liechtenstein sometimes though public
authorities might not respect these
rights for instance they may impose
excessive formalities not respect
deadlines or simply tell you that you
don't have rights you know you have if
this happens to you solve it is a quick
free service that can help solve it is a
network of national centres in all EU
countries working together to solve any
problems you might have when your EU
rights are not respected
all you have to do is go to the solvet
website and in your own language submit
your case solve it only needs to know
who you are what your problem is and
which authority you're complaining about
your country's solve it Center will
verify that a public authorities
involved the problem happened in another
EU country and that EU law has been Mis
applied they will let you know whether
or not your case can be handled by solve
it they might also ask you for more
information if necessary
you're solvet Center will hand over your
case to the Soviet Center in the country
where the problem occurred
that solvet Center will contact the
authority concerned and together seek
the best solution to your problem they
will do this within ten weeks
once your problem is solved you can
benefit from your rights in the EU
to learn more visit our website
brought to you by solve it